JENNIFER SHAW: Hi.
Thank you for the nice
very warm welcome.
I have never been so honored to
be on stage in my entire life,
so thank you for
letting me be up here.
I am here representing as a
founder of both New York Tech
Women and Bella
Minds, specifically
to talk about our
programs Bella Minds.
We talked a lot about
international women, and just
the amazing things
that Google is
doing to help them, the
support structure with all
these different platforms.
And I have a slightly
different focus,
just in that we're all
like very tired and ready
for Pinkberry's, so I
just have a few-- I really
like the pressure, like get
done, we have things to do.
But I have a few
questions for you guys.
Have you guys ever felt
excluded from something?
Like just-- yeah?
Yeah, me too.
Do you guys ever
feel like maybe you
dream too big, like
you have big ideas
and-- yay, there's
a few dreamers.
I love you.
So that's kind of me.
I got on this road
into tech making,
I actually didn't have a
professional technology
background.
My mom taught me
databases as a preteen.
That was her idea
of, like-- fun?
I don't know.
Which was great, but then
when I graduated high school
and was looking to
college, I was like, well,
clearly I don't need to
go to school for that.
I know everything.
So I didn't.
I went to school for
business, and sort of more
went down that path into
liaison role between technology
and business, which
is really kind of fun.
So I also encourage that as
much as I courage tech making.
But what happened is
that I moved to New York.
And things were
going really well,
I was doing a lot of research in
technology, software, wireless,
all sorts of things.
And I kind of ready
for the next step.
We mentioned I happen to
come from a background
in the Midwest.
And yeah, I did.
I picked up one day and
moved to New York on a whim.
And so a couple
years later, I just
didn't have enough
technology in my life.
And so I went out to find them.
And it was gross.
Really, the problem
that I didn't have
was that I felt excluded because
it was a male-dominated field.
I actually felt really
excluded, because I
didn't feel like the women
treated each other very well.
I'll give note that this
was several years ago,
and I don't think we're
having the same conversation
that we're having now.
So hopefully that's not
happening as much anymore.
But it was a real
problem, so that's
kind of what came
from New York Tech
Woman is that I wanted to create
an environment where everyone
felt welcome.
And it didn't matter like
what your background was,
what your title was.
Because we all know,
especially for those of us
here in New York, that are
first conversation's like, hi.
What do you do?
And I don't know about you
guys, but that doesn't really
define me very well-- more so
now than maybe it did, but I
was doing research in
like random tech products.
So it didn't really
define me very well.
And I thought, that's
just not very fair.
And so what I wanted to do
with New York Tech Women
was to create a very
all-inclusive environment,
because we have enough
problems as it is.
We shouldn't be our own battles.
So anyway, so a little
further down the road,
a couple years later, we'd
established New York Tech Woman
as a really strong presence
in helping women just
understand where their
place was in technology
and why they were there and
what they could do about it.
And frankly, I just
sort of started
to feel that there
was a little bit more.
Like New York's amazing culture
and there's a lot going on,
but with my Midwest
background, I just
felt that there was still
something really missing.
And I started getting
all these emails.
And it was a big
conversation about, well,
we need more diversity.
Do you happen to
have a woman who
can fill my blah, blah,
blah, tech position?
And I just felt so gross when
I would get those emails.
And in case you
guys didn't realize,
tokenism is also sexism.
And so that was a
real problem for me.
Yes, I want more
women in technology,
like more than I want
to eat most days.
But the problem right
now isn't that we
don't have enough
women in technology.
The problem is
that we don't have
enough people in technology.
And it'll be really glorious
when we get more of them
to be women.
But what I really
started to research--
and that just dug me down
kind of into a rabbit hole--
was that about 20% of our
country is just not online.
Also just coincidentally,
about 20% of our country
lives outside
metropolitan areas.
So I put kind of my history
of being in the boondocks--
and I'm telling you,
Carhenge is in the boondocks.
And I thought like, when
we talk about diversity--
and obviously today
is about gender
and I celebrate that
more than anything--
but true diversity
comes from every angle.
And so we started to realize
that the conversations were
happening in New York and in
bigger cities that, you know,
tech and the scenes
and the cultures.
But I realized that there was
a huge problem with getting
everyone in this
country connected
in this blanket of
network rather than just
these big hubs.
So I created Bella Minds, which
takes city-centric education
models and resources and
pairs them with small towns
in America.
So we actually take tech leaders
from New York City, Washington
DC, Boston-- Boulder even-- and
we place them into small cities
for live, hands-on education.
So I have one more
question for you guys.
Has anybody ever taken
an online course?
Yeah?
It went really well, right?
OK, leave your hands up.
Leave your hands up.
I took an online course.
Who finished?
Who finished it, like
all the way to the end?
Awesome, yeah.
Who retook another one
because it was so amazing?
Yeah.
So there's so much study
around the way that we learn.
And so what we've learned
with the community
is that online education
just doesn't cut it.
Think about this-- teach
technology with technology.
Like I'm going to learn
to code from code?
Hmm.
And I didn't think that
that was really quite right.
So I do have a big background
in education, and specifically
about education.
So we actually do live,
on-site training in small towns
in America, which
is really exciting.
I actually just got in,
literally this morning,
from being away at our
first pilot location.
So we launched in October.
We raised almost
$30,000 in crowdfunding.
I don't remember
which speaker-- which
one was talking
about crowdfunding?
But I want to talk to you.
Anyway, $30,000 in
crowdfunding to give 25 women
scholarships to
our first program.
So I have just
like a small story.
We built program,
we built curriculum.
We actually took an
Ivy League education,
pairing it with both business
school and technology.
Because think about what's
missing in the world
and what's required in
the world of technology.
Think of it on a scale-- like,
for you guys-- zero to ten,
right?
And a truly digital literacy,
like if you are technically
illiterate, like a true zero,
there are programs for you--
the local school is working
for you, probably some YMCA.
There's definitely like
some really great government
programs and even
school programs
that are helping
you combat that.
And then the other hand, we
now have programs everywhere
that are teaching tech
mastery skills, really
kind of pushing level on
that high ten level, right?
Really trying to
get it together.
But there's something
missing in this middle.
And so that's kind of the
goal of Bella Minds is to take
everything that's-- I
don't know, envision it,
like maybe a four
to like a seven.
And how do we make
sure that everybody
is at least over the
halfway mark, right?
We have a lot of
preaching where we
talk and talk and talk
about like, learn to code,
learn to code, learn to code.
And I agree-- learn to code.
But at the same
token, for those of us
that are at least
semi-technologists in the room,
please stop learning to code,
because I have to fix it.
Right?
So like, while I agree,
like everyone absolutely
should have this
in their resume,
but it's not for everyone.
And that's perfectly OK.
But it is the
language of tomorrow.
So that's actually what
Bella Minds is working on,
is how do we get them
past that barrier
where it really is
a true vocabulary?
Because we want to take them
from just being consumers
to actual tech creators
and tech makers, right?
I use "creators" because that
sounds better with my tag.
But to truly make things,
and to reiterate to them
that you can make
a lot of things.
You can create anything
on the internet.
But these are groups of
women and in situations
and environments where that's
just not brought up for them.
I'm just another-- because
I know we're all like really
anxious for the Pinkberry--
so like I'll just
try to keep it light.
Is anybody actually
from rural America?
Shoutout, Midwest, yay.
All right, so I
just want to hear
from a couple of that would
claim Midwest, what happened
when you came to New York,
assuming you're here now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JENNIFER SHAW:
OK, somebody else.
You?
Ohio?
Loveland, Ohio.
AUDIENCE: I made it to
Arizona [INAUDIBLE].
Loveland, Ohio.
I was there for 19 years.
People don't leave there.
JENNIFER SHAW: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They don't know
what goes on outside of--
JENNIFER SHAW: No, they don't.
So that's actually what
I learned-- no, they
don't know what happens outside
Loveland, or Lyons for that
matter.
And that's fine-- kind of.
And to be quite honest, that's
like a very American way
of view, right?
I don't know.
When I first moved
to New York, I
was like, these people think
like the world ends here,
right?
Like, we all know that we
live in a bubble in New York.
And so I think it's actually
more and American view,
not just like an Ohio or like
a New York view or a Nebraska
view.
But what do we have
to do to actually
really bridge the gap together?
And so my focus is on
mid-career women rather than
young children.
I have seven nieces.
I want them to be tech too.
But what happens is that we're
shy, in the next four years
or so, we're missing about
a quarter million people
to fill our tech jobs.
That's just in the US.
And right now, we're
kind of in a rob Peter,
pay Paul sort of situation.
We're importing about 17%
of all our tech talent
from around the world-- which
is glorious, thank heaven
for that, because it does
truly, truly breed the diversity
conversation.
But when we balance that with
the rest of the demographics
of the US and then
country and whatnot,
we're really not putting to
work the people that we have.
And if we want to
keep up as a country,
we actually have a
problem now, right?
We actually need women that
have worked at the bank,
and they've worked
at the vision office,
and they've worked at
the reception office
to actually start learning
these conversations,
because their background
is phenomenal.
We need to make sure that
today's teachers are actually
having this conversation.
So that's my focus
with Bella Minds,
is that as much as, yes,
we need a strong pipeline
and that everybody should
be mentoring a young woman,
I just strongly, strongly
encourage everyone in this room
to reach out with somebody
who just like really just
doesn't want to participate
in this conversation
and start talking to
them about the potential.
So age doesn't matter.
You can learn
something regardless.
So we actually just finished
our pilot program in Nebraska.
I did it on my hometown, which
was really pretty glorious.
And I did it with 10
people that I knew.
That seemed safe, until I
learned so much about it.
And so I think I'll just share
with you my biggest finding,
because honestly I haven't had a
chance to look at the research.
I've been gone.
But the biggest
finding is that we
built a program that was
one week, live-intensive,
with mentors on site for them.
And then we have a follow-up
eight-week program for them
so that they can actually
virtually understand
what that communication
looks like,
because that's that
middle mushy part-- logic
and problem solving and
working with remote teams
and understanding different
cultures and problem solving
and thinking about things.
It's not actually sitting
down and writing code.
And so the biggest
finding that I had
were two women in the
middle of our week
together who had never had
internet in their house.
It wasn't a matter of not
affording or not available--
it was seriously not a priority.
They just didn't care.
They had no idea what
tech could do for them,
or like what advantage
there was to them.
And by like day
three, two-- and I
think maybe a third woman-- went
out and installed high speed
4G to their house.
Right, so that to
me is like, I almost
don't care about like
the rest of the research,
because to me that speaks
for the rest of it.
It simply is just not a
priority for the world.
And unfortunately,
we just have to have
that for this country in order
for us to participate wholly
and to participate now, right?
We don't have a
problem in seven years
when my niece
graduates high school.
We have a problem now
in terms of tech talent.
So that's what I'm working
on with Bella Minds.
Yeah, I don't think
we're doing questions.
And I'll be really honest,
I'm going to keep it short.
You guys all want Pinkberry.
I want Pinkberry.
[INAUDIBLE]
It's tiring, it's
longer in the day.
But I do encourage
you to two things.
Again, make sure
that you reach out.
And I don't mean just reach out
to a young girl who needs help.
Make sure you reach out to
your mother and your sister
and your aunt, to your next-door
neighbor, like whatever
it means-- your bank teller,
spread the Gospel if you will,
that technology is just
so incredibly powerful.
It doesn't necessarily
mean that they
have to be the next
developer of Google.
But to participate in the
language is really important.
So reach out to somebody.
And I can help with
that if you need.
So that's Bella Minds.
And hopefully you'll
have questions later.
But thank you all for having
me here today to talk about it.
[APPLAUSE]